preston
is in dallas texas hi preston how are
you
hey dave hey dr g how's it going great
how can we help
so i just want to thank you first for
your teachings me my wife got on board a
couple years ago
we'd done some stupid had some cars a
couple new cars plowed through those
got them paid off and we just uh we just
moved on we bought a house we're on the
four five and six got our 20 percent
down everything's safe so i just want to
say uh
thank you for everything you're doing
for everybody way to go dude proud of
you
thanks and so today is more of a career
question i had so
um i guess shortened to the point i i
kind of have the
feeling uh that i'm undercompensated at
work and was kind of curious um
one if it was really really wise you
know to ask for a raise during these
especially during these um these hard
coronavirus times
is your company struggling
so we have back in
uh it's a larger company large um
publicly traded company but back
in march or so we did have some
furloughs and let some um
we were kind of in the service industry
so we did let some drivers and things go
due to um you know profitability and
revenues but we
have begun actually bringing some of
those back and hiring them so i think
what gives you the feeling you're under
compensated
i've been there for a couple years now
and i've taken on
uh i'm in a sales role with them taking
on quite a bit more
you know responsibility brought on new
accounts and i've been hitting
um pretty much all my goals except for
this this last quarter
no excuses but you know with the
coronavirus i was dead off a little bit
there but uh
for the most part i feel like i've been
doing a good job just haven't seen much
any any um compensation increase in the
last couple years
that's a different question that dave
asks you he asked you
how do you know you're under compensated
which to me dave you can tell me if i'm
wrong
is what are people in your area doing
the same level of work you're doing at
the same competency you are
what are they making versus i shook
hands with the company and said i'm i'm
going to come to work you for this
i'm going to put in my all i'm going to
be excellent at it and you're doing all
those things and they're doing what they
said they were going to do
paying you they're paying you what they
said they're going to
yeah yeah definitely i would say just in
some research and things
i believe that people in my area
in the same same position that i am in
are probably
10 to 15 percent higher and a little bit
more about the role i kind of came in as
in more of an inside
sales role and that's kind of involved
over the last couple years so it's okay
here's here's here's the way you
answered a role here here's the way you
answer the question how do i ask for a
raise
if you switch places with your leader
who's going to make the
the compensation decision uh what would
you want
a young go-getter like preston to do
if he wanted a race why would you give
preston a raise
i'll give you a hint you wouldn't give
him a raise
because he breathes air in and out
no not at all or he thinks he's been
working hard for a few years and he
should probably just get some more
no not at all either i'd say definitely
around those goals right
i think you want to make your boss look
good so hitting your goals revenue goals
making the company you know more money
is is probably one factor in it
and then two i would think what you guys
were just saying right what
what can i replace you for there's
someone else out there exactly
is you know the same or uh
you know what what does it cost to fill
your role basically or your position and
what you're getting
two examples that happened to me
personally
as a leader here uh example number one
is guy walks into my office and says hey
i pulled up a bunch of comp
uh issues off of google and off a
monster
and i might be wrong but here's what i
found i found this and this and this and
this
and um those are all ten thousand
dollars more than i'm making
and it if unless i did something wrong
on the internet
in looking doing a compensation research
here it appears looking at this
these data points not feelings
these data points that i'm off about 10k
on my comp
would you look at this with me and
consider raising me
if it's real that's k and he got the
raise by the way
okay okay second comp second
conversation was guy walks into my
office and says you know a guy
like me that has i've got 14 degrees i
got more degrees than a thermometer
a guy like me working in another company
makes makes uh twice what i make here
and uh i said well honey uh felicia i
said the the problem is this is a small
business and your raise is effective
when you are
and so the number of degrees you have is
not does not make you valuable
what you do what you kill and drag in
here that we share
is what is what makes you valuable from
an economics perspective
as a human being i value you but but
from an economics perspective
and so by the way that guy doesn't work
here anymore
and because he didn't like my answer uh
his rate you know so
you go in and just do what you said you
said i've been effective i feel like i'm
doing this
and i pulled some research and here's
what it's showing
what do you think uh did i do something
wrong or do you have other information
that i don't have that says that this
position
because i feel you know based on this it
looks like i might be due for some
compensation upgrades
what do you think about that and that's
not belligerent
it's not saying slapping your fist on
the table and saying i look this up and
you're underpaying me you
toxic jerks it's not any of that it's uh
going i'm just looking at this and going
guys that do what i do
seem to be making a lot more than i'm
making am i doing something wrong what
did i see here
and if you just switch shoes when you're
thinking about these things and think
about the
from the leader's perspective what would
you want
a go-getter like preston to do you don't
want to lose a preston
you want to keep them you want them on
the team what would you want them to do
i would want them to come in with more
than i've been here breathing air for
two years and so i need money
right it's there's a humility to hey
i've done my research i've done my
numbers here's my performance
i i love that approach dave i love the
humility of it
i also man i've spent years
working with young professionals that
was their first or their second job
and there is this expectation this this
of course i'm generalizing here but this
idea that
we shook hands i've done my job for a
year or two and
what are you gonna do for me now and
there's this this
basic expectation that you're just going
to keep keep picking me up picking me up
picking me up and
i always want to remind folks when you
shake hands with your employer and say
i'm going to come give it my all
and they say i'm going to give you this
the only time they screw you
is if they give you less than that
amount of money anything other than that
we agreed as what we agreed on
and um be good with that until you can
provide data points to the contrary
yeah i you know i i do run into that
that's kind of an entitlement mentality
i don't think preston's suffering not at
all not even he's got a different he's
got a different
take on it but but i think you're right
there's this thing it's kind of like a
like a union seniority thing or
something like you know i've been here
breathing air for 20 years
i have one year's experience 20 times
right and so i'm worth more
no you're not right you're still doing
the same stinking thing you're doing
what do you think about his question
just take into the global pandemic
is there a is there a a moment well i
think about this back at my house right
i can look at my wife and she's
exhausted she's been
packing boxes all day and helping him
moving that may not be the time to say
i don't like the way you're parked in
the car in the driveway could you scoot
it over two feet right i know there's a
season
or there's a moment to ask that that's
not a good idea right now is that is
that ever coming to play in business
or is business just business is business
well no i mean it's it's
everything's personal and so the the
question is
you know if you're asking a leader who
is barely making their numbers because
of covid
for more money you know it just seems
sensitive it's not it's not only
unsensitive it's impractical right
you know we don't make hardly any money
we're struggling to stay open and you're
coming here wanting to raise
right that's just tone deaf right you
know but
on the other hand there are companies
that have done okay uh
ramsay's done okay we've struggled
during this time and we had some
business units just live events all that
revenue just disappeared
right it's gone and virtually anyway um
except for virtually yeah no pun
intended building yeah and uh uh
but then other areas have gone way up
and so we've ended up
at about what we thought we were going
to be last year so
our budget projections are about on and
so
you know internally we've
started giving raises again and started
hiring again
and so in that environment even with
covet if somebody came up to one of us
and said i think
you know would you look at this with me
i think i'm off on my comp
but and you go oh well no you're a you
know you're a junior
right you're not a senior oh okay okay
all right well what have i got to do to
be a senior
no talking the humility question love it